yeah good morning Ian we have seen
inflation return above 10 brief respite
in July but here you can see back above
10 the number we last had in July if you
want to see the last time we saw
inflation at those kind of levels we're
talking back in the 1980s so these are
steep steep housing costs that are
inflation costs that are hitting
consumers at every level what's the
biggest driver of the increase well it's
food inflation up to 14 and a half
percent again a high we haven't seen it
since the 1980s and look at these are
the components that are driving this
inflation up we knew housing costs were
rising of course energy is a component
there food the big mover in this latest
month transport cost actually fuel costs
are falling back so transport not
contributing as much but still an
enormous amount and restaurants and
hotels of course many of their input
costs come back to food now we know the
chances is looking at the impact on his
70 billion pound black hole of these
figures because the 10.1 percent figure
in this month set the up rating if the
conservatives stick to their Manifesto
pledge for benefits now what might they
save were they to go instead with the
lower earnings figure at break the
manifesto commitment there'd be
political pain in terms of the balance
sheet for the chancellor 5.6 billion
pounds he would save in pensions
payments and two and a half 2.4 billion
if that was applied to benefits a total
of eight billion pounds that's pretty
attractive to a Chancellor looking at
potentially 70 billion pound black hole
but the personal cost to some of the
poorests in society is enormous the
numbers aren't as big but the pain is
very real if we look at disabled adult
if they went for that lower number we'll
be looking at 380 pounds less in their
annual budget a single adult with one
child nearly 500 pounds less a year and
a family that's renting and working
crucially with three children will be a
thousand pounds worse off so we can see
the personal cost to those impacted by
the very attractive savings doubtless to
a Chancellor who's got a massive black
hole to fill and the numbers have just
got harder because inflation is back up
above 10 percent